foreign
back to the
Frameworks and principles in
Atomic habits are there any sections
chapters principles anything that you
wish more people paid attention to right
there's something that you put in
that gets glossed over or maybe who
doesn't stick
for whatever reason as much as other
things but you think it or these things
are important I mean I certainly have
examples from from my books from like
[ __ ] like I don't know if I made a
mistake in the way I presented that but
it's it's not getting its Fair Shake in
the sense of its importance well
sometimes you might just be like maybe I
thought that idea was better than it
actually was you know there might be
that too there might be that yeah I have
a couple so there are two things that
came to mind the first one is there's a
little example I give in the book about
maybe about halfway through or 40
through where I talk about having a
pre-game routine and kind of doing
things in the same sequence each time in
the same Order each time and that helps
get you in the mindset and kind of
initiate the Habit so I you know I
played baseball through college and I
have the same pregame routine that I did
before each game and that kind of like
flips this switch in your mind where
it's like hey like it's time to compete
now you know like it's game mode
or the example I gave in the book
was this guy who he would do his writing
at the library and he would go to the
library sit at the same desk each day
and put on his headphones and play the
same playlist and that that little
sequence was a pre-gamer team that got
him in the mindset to do his writing
habit and one day he turned around and
realized that no music was playing he
just had his headphones on and it was
just it was just silent but he was
writing and he was like 20 minutes into
writing before he realized it and it's a
good example of how like just that
sequence of doing it the same way each
time and having that same pregame
routine that little ritual got him in
the mindset he didn't even need to press
play that day he was just ready to write
and so if you can come up with what that
little pregame ritual is for you that
can be a great way to initiate a habit
and I don't usually see people talk
about that I think actually I've heard
some examples like this on on your
podcast previously Tim like I think when
you talk to Josh waitskin at one point
he at some sometime he gave this example
maybe was in his books maybe it was a
conversation with you where he was
competing in this national competition
martial arts and he was told that he was
going to compete at one time and they
came up to him and he was like sleeping
or laying on a on a bench and they were
like hey sorry timing was wrong you're
actually up in like six minutes and he
was like normally I would have been
thrown off but he had this little
pregame ritual that he did and he tried
to as he developed it over time it
started out maybe it was 10 minutes and
then he tried to compress it so it was
seven minutes and then it was three
minutes and then eventually got it down
to where his little ritual was just
something he did for like 30 seconds so
they woke him up on that bench and he's
got to compete six minutes later but all
he needed was 30 seconds to kind of like
get in the right frame of mind and he's
like okay now I'm ready to go and so
those pregame rituals can be really
powerful if you make it your own and
come up with something that like you do
every time and it helps get you into the
mindset to compete or to perform
yeah for sure Josh
has given could be his personal example
he's also talked about Marcelo Garcia
whose nine-time world champion Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu arguably Maybe
uncontroversially probably one of the
best if not the best who's ever competed
in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu who who has a
similar ability to throw a switch
minutes before he'll compete in a world
championship about and it applies
furthermore
to most writers who I have had on the
podcast will have some type of
boot up sequence much like this person
who went to the library and people can
take solace in the fact there's no
consensus
there's no consensus it's very personal
I think you need to make it your own you
know yeah and there are also people who
will say like yeah I just dick around
for the first two hours I get literally
but that's not wasted time because it
takes that long for me to just like
Scribble or complain about my day on the
page so that I'm filling the page or
something and then it turns into
an hour later some paragraph that is the
Nugget of the beginning of what I need
to work on that day so it's not
eventually the pain of not doing it
becomes greater than the pain of doing
it and they take it yeah yeah right or
Neil game and he's like yeah I'd go to
the cabin and I'm
I don't have to write but I'm not
allowed to do anything else
I love that that's great yeah and PJ
Novak also has his own approach who's
done a lot about a ton of television and
film work
and
for me like right now you know working
on fiction for the first time
over the last let's call it six months
finding the routine like how I make the
coffee when I sit down the exact
sequence how I set up my laptop on the
laptop stand I mean it's very yeah
bunkish but it does make a big
difference